what an indictment on this government to
do this to the very people that has held
this NHS together not just through the
pandemic but in an NHS that has been run
into the ground and in crisis caused by
this government but where do we go from
here well of course our nursing staff
will not do anything that isn't legal we
will continue to have strike action on
Sunday evening and again on Monday but
we won't be taking strike action on the
2nd of May a our nurses have carried out
very safe legal action to date and Steve
Barkley can continue to threaten them
with their registration and it can
continue if he wishes to to drag them
through Court proceedings but what he
needs to do is get into a negotiating
room and start to talk to the nurses of
England sort out this dispute and allow
them to get back to their work this is
no way to treat them